I know I know in many ways 2013 was a
terrible year for libertarians and
limited government Obamacare started
signing people up
Democrats have Republicans rolled back
sequestration cuts and we found out the
NSA was cataloging every phone call
tweet and snapchat message ever sent but
here are three reasons why 2014 might
well be the most libertarian year ever
last fall's rollout of Obamacare
complete with non-functioning website
and irrefutable evidence that the
president lied about your ability to
keep your plan if you liked it has
helped wake people up to the
inefficiency and assembling nature of
government that will only get worse as
the program actually starts providing
health care
between Obamacare ongoing and continuing
NSA revelations and so much more
mistrust of government is near record
levels and a record high percentage
seventy-two percent agrees that the
government represents the biggest threat
to the country in the future
congressional approval ratings are at or
near historic lows with some poll
showing approval ratings as low as 7%
Barack Obama's ratings are better but
still terrible for any second term
president not named Nixon incumbents
will be under massive attack in the
midterms successful candidates in both
major parties have no choice but to
rally around libertarian themes such as
reducing government spending empower
drug legalization marriage equality and
to restrain foreign policy of course if
things don't pan out for libertarians at
least we can go to Colorado in
Washington State and chill out in a way
that is finally legal after decades of
misguided prohibition for Reason TV I'm
Nick blessing